And finally, New Rule.
In the future,
all American schoolkids
must be made
to study the constitution.
-Not ours, Brazil's.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Because plainly,
that one is working
a lot better
than the one we have.
America ran a very clear
scientific experiment
with Brazil recently,
where we faced
the exact same situation,
and let's just say,
when it comes to democracy,
we're the ones who got waxed.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Brazil, you know.
Yeah. Bolsonaro.
The coup, yeah. Yeah.
(BILL MAHER LAUGHS)
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Needed to stroke the audience
more on that one, I guess.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-So... (LAUGHS)
So, here's what happened.
In 2020,
American incumbent president,
Donald Trump, a thrice-married
far-right populist,
lost his re-election bid.
And then embarked
on a campaign of outright lies
to convince his supporters
the election had been rigged,
which resulted in the siege
of the American Capitol
on January 6th.
(CROWD CHANTING)
Fast forward almost two years
to the day, January 8th, 2023,
and Jair Bolsonaro,
Brazil's thrice-married,
far-right populist
incumbent president,
known as the Trump
of the tropics, repeats the--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-He was.
Repeats the Trump playbook
exactly after he loses
his re-election bid,
and thousands
of his supporters storm
-the Brazilian capital.
-(INDISTINCT CLAMORING ON VIDEO)
Both insurrections fail.
But here's
where we see the difference
between a healthy democracy
and one that's hanging
by a thread.
After January 8th,
almost all of Brazil
turned on the plotters
and made Bolsonaro a pariah.
But after January 6th,
Trump went on
to his winter palace in Florida
to accept tributes
and re-plot in opulent splendor.
-Bolsonaro...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Bolsonaro also went to Florida
where he ate by himself
at a KFC.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-That's a real picture.
I love you.
I love you, man. (LAUGHS)
Today, only six percent
of Brazilians
say they support the mob
that sacked their capital.
But in America,
Trump's more popular than ever
and on track to regain power.
In Brazil, not only
has Bolsonaro been banned
from running again
anytime soon,
but the country united
around their new leader,
who walked arm-in-arm
with congressional leaders
from the Left and Right
in solidarity
against the uprising.
Arm-in-arm.
In America, no arm-in-arm.
-Arms, yes.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Plenty of that.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
And threats.
Most Republicans
were literally scared to death
to do the right thing.
They didn't wanna be hung
like Mike Pence,
or castrated
like Lindsey Graham.
-(SETH MACFARLANE LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Because... (LAUGHS)
The thing is, in Brazil,
their conservative party
is where ours was
during Watergate,
when Republicans were willing
to throw Nixon under the bus
because they still had ideals
higher than owning the libs.
So, what changed?
Well, part of it's structural.
Their constitution
is only 35 years old.
-Ours is 235, and it looks it.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
We not only
still use old-timey words
like gerrymandering,
we still practice it.
The average
Republican congressman
is in a safe seat
with an electorate
he chose himself.
And he's only scared
of two things.
A primary opponent
with more guns
-on his Christmas card...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...and getting a nickname
from Trump.
Trump has proven
that in America,
you can absolutely attempt
a coup.
And at the very least,
there's no
immediate repercussions.
The only way we are allowed
to punish a president
is through impeachment,
where the jury is the Senate.
Except California has 68 times
the population of Wyoming,
and yet we both get
two senators.
We both get two jurors.
In Brazil,
elections are overseen
by a special electoral court,
with judges who serve two terms.
We don't have that.
We have
a partisan Supreme Court
whose terms expire when they do.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-ADAM SCHIFF: It's true.
And who are mostly picked
by presidents
who lost the popular vote.
And our elections
are run by the states,
so you got a hodgepodge
of 50 different election systems
with 50 different rule books.
And we're the only nation
on earth
that chooses their election
by way of an electoral college,
which is somehow even worse
than regular college.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
And if all that
isn't bad enough,
it takes America two months
to count and certify the votes,
which gives the losers
plenty of time
to plot and make mischief.
In Brazil,
popular vote always wins.
Everybody goes to the polls
on the same day,
and the official commission
declares the winner that night.
And then everyone goes outside
and flashes their tits.
-(SETH LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
As opposed to here,
because about 40 years ago,
we changed
television news gathering
from a public service
to a division of the company
that has to make a profit.
We let various shit-disturbing,
ratings-hungry news outlets
call the election
and tease out the suspense
like it's the Golden Bachelor
giving out the final rose.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
It used to be people's opinions
were shaped by the news.
Now, the news is shaped
by people's opinions.
Opinions.
It's all we hear
in the media all day long
when we're not hearing it
from our friends on Facebook.
-And by friends, I mean--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-By friends, I mean Russians.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
And there's one more thing.
We're just a shittier people
than we used to be.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(ADAM LAUGHS)
-Sorry.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Sorry,
but we ran the experiment,
and we lost.
In Brazil, the politics
of grievance has its limits.
Here, it doesn't.
There are 172 election deniers
currently sitting in Congress,
but Republicans
only threw out one guy.
And ironically,
he was from Brazil.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(LAUGHS)
So, yes.
Our conservatives deserve
the lion's share of the blame.
They're the ones
who are sticking with Trump.
But it's also
not that simple, guys.
It's also the fact
that since Watergate,
the parties
have flipped personalities.
Democrats used to be
the party of the working class,
and Republicans
were the elitist,
chardonnay-sipping assholes,
the snobs on the winning side
of the diploma divide.
But that got switched up.
And people really hate a snob,
enough, in fact,
to vote for Trump,
who recently said,
"It's nice to have a strongman
running your country."
Well, many Brazilians remember
when it wasn't.
They lived
under a real dictatorship,
less than 40 years ago.
And so, they have an immunity
that we do not.
It would be nice
if we could get that immunity
without having
to get the disease.